à Paris, des files d'étudiants
se forment aux abords
de résidences universitaires.
Ces quelques centaines de jeunes
n'attendent pas d'assisteririri.
mais plutôt de recevoir
de l'aide alimentaire. é é é é t
- Parfois, on doit se priver.
rfrfois, quand on fait, par
exemple, j'ai cours du matin
jusqu'au soir, peut-être à midi
parce que voilà, si je mange
dehors, c'est trop cher.
- Depuis 2016, l'organisme
de restaurants ou supermarchés.
Des produits que ces étudiants.
YOUNÈS MOUSSALI,
bénévole, Linkee
- Semaine après semaine,
ne s'arrête pas, que les
bénéficiaires sont de plus
en plus nombreux, qu'ils ont
de
- Au cours des derniers mois,
ce centre de disibibution a vu
la demande doubler.
Déjà confrontés aux loyerstata,
ces étudiants parisiens, comme
tous les Français, doivent
maintenant s'ajuster à
C'est sans compter, la hausse
des coûts du chauffage
et de l'énergie.
- Aujourd'hui, je recevaisonono,
l'électricité a encore augmenté,
donc, c'est pas rcrcément
les nouvelles qui font le plus
plaisir.
- Des dededededededededededededs
et allocations.
Pour ces étudiants, dont
certains sont étrangers, le coup
de main offert par Linkee permet
produits frais et de meilleure
qualité.
- Du coup, ça fait plaisir
de ne pas devoir dépenser
20 euros pour faire des mememem.
- Je vous donne deux natures,
c'est deux nurures.
- Vu le contexte économique, les
organismes d'aide alimentaire
primimimimimimimimimimimimimimis
prochains mois, en plus de faire
face à des défis, comme celui
de l'approvisionnement
en nourriture.
- Bonjour.
CHARLOTTE DOUVILLE, soutien
Restos du coeur dans Yvelines
- Ça nous touche, dans la mesure
où le coût de nos e e e e e e es
élevé qu'il ne l'était il y a
un an.
- Pour garnir leurs tablettes,
les Restos du coeur, fondés par
reçoivent aussi des dons.
- Si ça allait bien, vous ne
seriez pas là, je me doute.
Ne vous inquiétez pas.
- Le gouvernement français s'est
les organismes qui luttent
contre la précarité alimentae.e.
Mais les obstacles demeurent
grands. Comme celui de continuer
d'attirer ces miquququququququqt
à l'organisme d'exister.
Depuis la pandémie, recruter est
plus compliqué.
Les Restos du coeur
- C't t évident. Même là, vous
voyez aujourd'hui, là, on voit
bien, il manque un bénévole, d .
- Heureusement qu'il y a des
associations qui nous aident.
- L'aide des organismes offre à
appartement de 16 mètres carrés
payé, les ressources restantes
pour bien se nourrir sont
- Clairement, je dois choisir
des trucs, je choisis les moins
chers, des trucs que je n'achètx
pas me les permettre.
- Des choix difficiles de plus
en plus fréquents, dans un pays
gouvernement, la précarité
alimentaire  e en augmentant.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, Paris